what inspired you to be an actor my my
life and my experience I survived the
Blood Diamond Awards early on I was
given up on my parents to another
stranger that they met at the camp to go
to live in Senegal my parents found me a
couple years later and I'm an only child
so I've always and I've lived in so many
different countries have always had just
me because I parents are too busy
working so I didn't know that was our
acting was was I'd go to my own little
world and be princess SIA or be you know
angry see i'll be different sears and I
acted out and that's just what I was
doing but when I grew up I was like okay
I need to go to school I didn't someone
I took psychology and social work and I
worked with newcomers in Canada and
their stories that I heard and that and
I kept thinking myself this would be
amazing if I could play parts and tell
the world these stories you know and I
know there are writers out there that
can do this and that's what I was like
you know what I'm just dropping out of
university and I go to school and from
there got a scholarship to go to two
different from schools and now here I am
yeah I went to Vancouver from school in
Canada I got a part-time scholarship
there and then New York room academies
on my work and I got a part scholarship
for that I'm not a full but some of it
and came up here gosh uh so many people
me I you know grow up I watch a lot of
lot of thumbs um you know the great
since I watched and everyone wants to be
especially an African American actor
once belated as I watched and I really
really look up to Forest Whitaker as
well and lately I've been getting so
obsessed with Morgan
Freeman is everything about him on
camera just like screams this passion is
like raw raw energy as love I love his
work but as i get my personal life I
always wanted to do it I grew up on a
farm so I didn't have that outlet where
I'm from and then I got into some things
in high school and then I when I got
into college I audition for my first
play and I got like one of the lead
roles and I was like oh this is what I
want to do so it was a weird rig path
but only because it was like what do you
want to be when you grow up and you know
first you have your parents ideas of
which one being grow up and then you
start thinking well I don't know what I
want to be and I liked acting because
you could be anything and I thought oh
they'll be happy because I'm everything
like I'm a doctor I'm a lawyer oh I'm
kid I'm this I'm not and I I really love
that about acting and my grandmother she
was the only one who really supported me
when I initially said hey I want to add
she had me in the church plays and she
had me doing spoken word contest and she
really embraced it and wasn't like oh
you're not gonna make any money and I I
thought that was great so I guess my
grandma in a way when I was a kid I
loved Disney movies and I always like
it's cliche but I always dreamed of
being like the first Filipino princess
that sounds so funny I still had the
dream till now but I always dreamed of
just being like the cute voiceover of a
princess or something so after like
watching disney movies i told myself at
a young age like i felt that i just love
to sing and love to act and told my
parents about it and I was really
grateful that they supported it you know
I was put into singing lessons dancing
and acting and from then until now I'm
still doing it I mean I just want to
grow into my craft but basically i
started with disney um mostly white men
I think I don't really know I mean I I
think a lot of it is just being having
being a kid with wild imagination and
and you know it's just how you're born I
think I've always been that kid who's
had a wild imagination so I've always
been into storytelling somewhere along
the way I started watching you know old
movies and and I fell in love with you
know like Brando and De Niro and and and
and James Dean and all these you know
Jack Nicholson you know and and a lot of
it was just watching old movies I
remember the first time I saw um rebel
without a cause I was 12 e 12 13 years
old and I drew borrowed it from a
library and I remember I watched it and
I remember recognizing that what he was
doing in that movie was different from
anything else that I'd seen on TV you
know at the time you're watching TV and
there's really no like great acting
right and you're watching action you
know movies on the big screen and I was
like there's something and him being a
teenager identified with that and there
was something so interesting and rich
and powerful and present about that
performance I think that was the first
time where I was like he's not he's
doing something different he's literally
just behaving on camera and they
happened to catch it that was a bit of a
seminal moment for me you know but you
know I mean as an asian american kid in
this country i didn't grow up with a lot
of minority heroes on the big screen you
know other than obviously bruce lee and
jet li and and john loan and you know
some of the other more theatre kind of
like actors but on the big screen you
know it was
the white men oh god I was I was 12
years old and I watched this movie
called the gamer with gerard butler and
logan lerman and I had a huge crush on
Logan Lerman so i told myself i could
only meet him and marry him and be his
wife if I got into the acting industry
so I took acting lessons and I gave up
after two years I was thinking that this
is nothing for me and I got into writing
and then I don't know what how are we
out my theatre teacher came just to me
in high school and she asked me if I
could help her with the production I was
like you know sure I have time so did it
and then I I was on stage and then I
just I don't know it made me so happy to
be up there to tell a story and to make
the audience feel something so they
could escape their normal life and that
experience just reminded me I don't know
my love for acting that I had a couple
of years back so I pursued acting in
London and in Hamburg for a while and
then I wanted to get more into movie
because or movie and TV because I was
very found on theater over there and I
asked my mom and my mom was totally
against it she's like never because it's
so far away from Hamburg I'm from
Hamburg just I'm German I was so far
away from there but I guess I convinced
her because I wrote down like how much
will cost and you know what I will fill
my days with and all that and yeah now
i'm here i'm trying to pursue my dream
to you know be remembered and to make
people escape reality yeah my inner
child live and you know be creative